Hi and welcome back to another
VC libraries Open code review.
Today we'll be looking at PR
3322 by our contributor Tyler
Brawl and this is implementing
another part of the paper
HE2321R2 adding another views to
the view to the ranges libraries
to views zip transform. So
previously Tyler contributed the
zip view and now we've got zip
transform. We just does
something a little bit
different.
He's got a very nice PR message
here that's explaining all the
stuff that's being implemented.
So we've got the our tracking
issue 2252.
That lists the overall paper. I
can open that up and associate
LKG issues because this is only
implementing, as I recall, one
out of four views we've got zip
view, zip, transform view
adjacent and adjacent transform.
So this is basically Part 2 out
of four, so we won't be seeing
the feature test macker here. We
only define those when the
feature is fully implemented.
But there are some LWG issues
which are bug fixes against the
standard that are relevant so.
Let me open up, please. OK, so
we've got the paper as a whole.
We've got two LWG issues. Tyler
also notes that there is usage
of decay Copy language feature
that's in C + 23. The compiler
doesn't have that. So.
So Tyler is implementing this
essentially manually, which is a
reasonable workaround. So let's
take a look at these LWG issues
as a quick refresher. This is
getting rid of some comparison
operators because they can be.
Umm generated for us I believe.
Let's see.
OK. Yeah, yeah, we we only need
to provide equal and spaceship.
So this is simplifying and then
this one.
Is changing one of the
requirements from copy
constructible to move
constructible?
Umm, it looks like there were
simply on.
A missed edit from a previous
patch paper, so hopefully this
wording has been integrated to
the leaves working paper. We
just got a new working paper
4928. This is now linked from
our repos readme thanks to a new
contributor who updated our
README so I can go over to rain
zip transform iterator and look
for the wording.
If the if this working paper
4928 UM has been updated, then
we only need to look at it. We
don't need to look at all these
LWG issues as well. Hopefully
this is the correct spelling. If
not, I'll open up the bookmark.
There we go.
OK, so sorry for jumping around.
In the synopsis, we should be
seeing only equal and spaceship.
For the zip transform view
iterator. So this is zip
transform view iterator Scroll
down.
Equal and spaceship OK, so we're
only seeing that. That's great.
This issues integrated and the
other one is in a range of
transform overview.
Which is.
Below now this is the iterator.
Scroll up Yep, ranges of
transform overview and bullet
.211 says if move constructible.
Two on one if move
constructible. OK, so both of
these issues has have been
integrated into the latest
working paper, which is great.
We only need to look at the
final fused version. This is the
original proposal. So zip
transform view.
Is.
Uh oh, this is a sorry. This is
a patch paper. OK, so this is
also definitely been fused in.
This makes the zip transform
view constrained on move
constructible.
As of transform view.
This is, yeah. Is it transform
view is constrained to move
constructible. So this catch
paper has also been integrated.
Great. So we don't need to go
look at 5 different layered
things or whatever. We only need
to look at the latest WP.
OK. And then other contributors,
Frederick SA, Tim Song, CPP have
been reviewing this greatly
appreciated the PR has already
been revised. So I will now
start looking at this. So let's
go over to files change.
Umm.
So I think forger lines of
product code and 800 lines of
tests are there about. Let me
split this.
Side by side view OK.
OK zip transform view, where is
the synopsis.
Ranges library.
Sometime I'm gonna faster
quickly scanning through this.
I'm like, whoa, ranges. I
haven't seen these points
before. These are adapters. Zip,
transform, view as a lot of
adapters.
OK, so this is the actual
section. Oh, but I wanted the
overview.
Here we go synopsis.
Let's see. It's a little bit
annoying that things are sort of
split, but this is just how the
standard specify stuff. OK, so
here we go. On the other thing,
of course, we want to look out
for is modules. We want to make
sure all the standard
identifiers are exported. I
believe this should just be the
classic transform view and the
actual views of transform. So
I'll look out for that. Maybe I
can actually scan for it now. So
I don't forget.
Umm, this is grinding
friendship.
Zip transform view itself is
exported perfect. The great
thing is that that applies to
all the Member functions. All
the nested classes, so we don't
care about any of them for the
purposes of modules don't need
to, can't in fact can't export
deduction guys, they're just
automatically attached, and then
the actual zip transform is
exported. OK, so modules is
perfect.
OK.
Nothing else is going on up
here, so we can go directly to
the specification of zip
transform.
That was in adapters zip.
OK, welcome back to this. OK, so
let's look at the easy files
first. Uh, why versus core has a
comment on what's being
implemented. Use zip transform
is being implemented, so we
dropped that and we just say
missing views of JSON and views
JSON transform without a comma.
Perfect, no feature, just macro
update at this time as I
mentioned.
A new test is being added so
Tyler is updating test dot list.
This is great. This makes sure
that it will be picked up by the
new test harness. It is in
sorted order. Clearly the
spelling is correct. That's
perfect. We've got list of
compiler options. This looks
like the previous zip one.
I this does require strictness.
I think this came up with.
The Zip view review that it is
incompatible with permissive
minus. I think I will do a quick
refresher and see if we can find
that just so we're.
Remembering what it is, it's not
open anymore.
I think Tyler might have liked
this from the PR button. I'll
just search for it from scratch.
OK this one.
Is October. October is like a
lifetime ago. I can't possibly
remember anything that helps.
OK, I'm gonna scroll through.
I guess it would have. It would
have come up in for that list,
but UM.
OK, we didn't have any actual
comments there. Did anybody say
strict?
Nope, nobody said strict. Maybe
this didn't come up.
OK, it wasn't actually called
out here.
But I seem to recall that it
also had strictness.
It did require struct.
OK.
Ah, this comment explains it.
That that's that's why I was
remembering. It says zip. You
iterator defines ADL overloads
argument dependent lookup for
ITER swap and it remove. That's
why it requires strict mode.
It's not unique to zip. You all
view types whose iterators
defined overloads. OK so is that
true for zip transform view
we've got the standard specified
zip transform view where is its
iterator. Here's iterator. If
there's ADL overloads for ITER,
swap and move, then that causes
the problem.
I'm not seeing it yet.
Is that out?
This is the class, so you
wouldn't get ADL overloads here.
You would get them at top level.
That's interesting.
Sorry for scrolling, I know it's
hard to keep up on the video.
Ah, am I missing anything here?
This is the iterator.
This is the end of the class
definition.
I don't see it or swapping move.
Here's a Sentinel for zip
transform view.
Some operator minuses equals.
OK, that's interesting. What
does zip view look like? Do they
differ here?
Uh.
This one doesn't define its own
iterator type.
I was, if you does not ohh
because it.
That I catch that no zip
transform vehicle.
I know it does, it does. I I was
just. I was just scrolling
Ohh.
through it.
But I didn't see an inter swap
and move for it, so here's the
transform view.
It makes sense that there
wouldn't be in it or swapping
move.
Much like for about their
regular transform view, because
OK.
Uh, because you're transforming.
the the the result of
dereferencing the iterator is
result of calling a function.
So it remove and ITER swap
wouldn't make any sense, right?
Right, you're.
There's nothing to move or swap.
There are ephemeral results.
Yeah, you're. Yeah. You're
making. Yeah. Phantom. Yeah.
Phil is a good word.
OK. So that's interesting this
so that indicates that maybe
this does not need to be
stripped. So the question I
always have when I see something
like this where this came up a
while ago.
So where we were using the
strict matrix, meaning requiring
permissive minus on everything a
bit more than we absolutely
needed to, and we grudgingly
permit CPP latest with the
permissive mode. So our new
convention is to use just the
concepts latest matrix whenever
we can and only add the strict
part if it's absolutely
necessary. So it wasn't
necessary for zip view as Casey
mentioned. And I eventually
Yeah.
deduced there is an asymmetry
here. It should probably not be
necessary for zip view.
And if it is, we'd like to
understand why.
Umm so I will link.
You can probably click on that
resolve comment of mine.
Which is asking does this really
needs the strict matrix?
Ohh.
Oh, here. Oh, here we go. OK.
There's there's Nicole asking
Ohh no it isn't. I can't believe
it and so it down.
and then talk about this. You
did comment, you talked about
author, strict Meow crackdown.
And.
See.
Yeah, it is specifically it
removing your swap.
Yeah. So I I think I think it
should not necessarily be.
Required here.
Yeah. So I want what I want to
do is I want to link this thing
while it's. I'll just look for
views zip. So let me go back to
the room, the repo because I
don't know how to get to this
faster.
Got a code test test.
Like for views zip.
There we go.
And list.
Get Y for permalink.
Copy or shift select this OK.
OK, so close this first comment.
Is the strict matrix required
for.
Zip.
Transform.
Zip needed it.
As explained by.
This comment I'll say this
comment, even though your
comment would also be
applicable. Blah.
However, there is an
intentional.
Semetary between I'm zip and
zip.
Transform.
And that uh, no.
Zip transforms Iterator doesn't
have ADL overloads of.
Enter move.
And it or swap now credit Casey
as Casey Carter explained, zip
transform produces.
He femoral.
Results due to the
transformation.
Umm.
I'll just leave it at that.
Therefore.
Uh, and saying therefore, can we
remove the strict requirement
and have the tests still pass?
Or is something else?
Blocking it. OK, phrase it as a
question. Let's make sure this
is all not typoed. Is the strict
matrix required for zip
transform? Zip needed it as
explained by this comment.
Explain ADL overloads. Strict
leads matrix. However this is
on.
However, this is unintentional.
Asymmetry between zip and zip
transform zip transforms
iterator doesn't have a DL
overloads of ITER move and ITER
swap, as Casey explained zip
transform.
Wow, that CSS is getting really
messed up as case explained zip
transform produces ephemeral
results due to the
transformation. Can we remove
the strict requirement? Have the
test pass or something else
blocking that? OK start review.
And then to avoid overloading
the compiler, the test is split
up into a bunch of different
parts. This is copied from the
other tests, and I assume it's
still necessary here, so I'm not
gonna question that defined to
Simply put forward bidirectional
and random. OK, I'll keep a
lookout when we actually review
that and I forgot to check, we
do have our copyright license
banner here. Perfect. Same for
the test. I'll quickly look at
that. I'll go to the product
code next. Copyright license.
OK, looks good.
OK, let's look at the product
code.
OK. What are we looking at here?
Maybe can I move the splitter a
bit?
Uh.
OK, that kind of helps.
It's a little bit small. Yeah.
OK, I know that's really small,
but I'm mostly focused on the
code right now.
OK, so what's happening here? We
got the classic original zip
view. Iterator is now granting
friendship.
And it is granting Tim highly
templated friendship. So
unfortunately we do have to say
class here.
Uh. Granting friendship to this
thing.
Interesting. OK, so this should
all match template move
constructible, under score
capital, funk import, range, dot
under score capital views.
I'm not super happy that this
has views. Instead of you types.
I would prefer for this to be
exactly copied.
Requires view of views and da,
da, da and size dot that thing
is greater zero and as object V
here I'm just mentally diffing
or visually diffing. Yeah, and
I'll looks good and can
reference.
Yep, that's all the same. It is
indeed a class. The only thing I
have a concern with is views
versus view types. Maybe that
was done to avoid wrapping. It
seems that these are almost
exceeding 120 columns and that
if it said view type should
wrap, my psychic power is is
they're telling me that this was
the reason. So.
Yeah, it's getting pretty close.
Uh. Maybe not too much. It's
only mentioned once.
If they said view futures, yeah,
that's the thing. I can't even
spell. What's my brain doing?
No. Have you tried to totally
fit?
Yeah, this should. This should
be view types. I don't see any
reason for them to differ. I'll
comment. It's an epic.
Let me get this.
Nitpick this says.
Here I copy paste to avoid typos
views instead of view types I.
Although.
This has no mechanical
difference.
But I would prefer to see the
UM.
Friendship exactly match the
definition.
OK Nitpicked this as views
instead of view types. This has
no mechanical difference, but I
prefer to see the friendship
exactly match the definition.
The only reason for them to
differ would be is.
If oh oh, that's right. OK,
there is a reason I just had to
scroll up. We're not in a top
level class here. We're in a
nested class. This is iterator
is Const, but it's nested within
zip view and that is templated
on view types. OK, so you can't
reuse the identifier view types
and in other situations. Usually
when granting like shared putter
friendship to another type will
say like other. So that's why I
was momentarily caught off guard
when I didn't see other here.
Umm.
It is reasonable to say, oh oh,
there's a data member named
views like whatever we choose,
we lose.
Is this technically shadowing?
This is using the identifier.
As a template parameter.
And there's a data member name
views.
I don't know if you can
necessarily take the decltype,
but this is too close to
shadowing that I like.
OK, so there's a reason for it
to be different, but I don't
like views here.
If it said other views, I would
be OK.
Yeah, other views is probably
the simplest way to handle this.
OK, let me rephrase this.
Nitpick.
I realized the.
Let's see.
I see that this is avoiding the
name.
View types.
Get back.
I see that this is choosing a
different name for.
View types.
Which appears.
In the parent class zip view
above.
But this is slightly confusing
shadowing.
Because the parent class has a.
Views.
Data member. I recommend
choosing another name.
Such as.
Under score other.
Views. UM.
We have a good example. Uh, let
me search in the repo real
quick.
Here we go. I was thinking other
ties where we usually see this
with friendship.
We we have an span.
Of this is a converting
constructor. I think we might
use tire Utah for.
I shared putter.
I think other views is fine.
Which?
Well, avoid all shadowing.
And make the renames purpose
slightly more obvious. OK,
perfect.
Nitpick, I see that this is
choosing a different name for
view types, which appears in the
parent class view above, but
this is slightly confusing
shadowing because the parent
class has a views data member. I
recommend choosing another name
such as under score capital.
Other views, which will avoid
all shadowing and make the
renames purpose slightly more
obvious.
OK.
One declaration down, friend.
Grant friendship to zip
transform view interesting that
there's a relationship between
the iterators. We'll see.
It's interesting that nothing
else is ohh if zip transfer of
view needs to reach into this,
that's why. OK, so we're gonna
expect zip transform view to
need that iterator. OK does have
an interview. OK, it's gonna be
why. OK, so onwards.
See, I know the standard is a
small here. I don't want the
code to wrap if I can avoid it.
Maybe that's the best I can do.
Maybe zoom out a bit.
OK.
OK, so we've got the export. As
previously mentioned, we've got
let me switch over to highlight
here.
OK, we've got a template move
constructible, F is move
constructible, under score
capital funk input range dot
under score, capital view types
OK. This requires that all those
view types be a view and da da
da.
And that we have more than zero
of them size of dot dot views is
greater strictly Brian, Zero and
F which is funk has got to be an
object type and we've gotta
satisfy the regular invocable
concept funk ref. So it's gotta
be an L value function object
range reference T views dot Yep.
Here I'm making sure that we've
got all of the lvalue references
and so forth because they are
important when asking all of
these concept questions and our
internal helper concept for can
reference the invoke result type
of funcraft, which is freff on
range reference T. OK, so all
that exactly matches perfect
class zip transform view.
Ohh, I'm looking at the
iterator, but it matches the
parent as well. Uh. Yeah, this
is gonna be exactly the same. So
Yep.
Classic transform view there is
publicly from view interface
that transform view function
view types. Yep.
OK, so private data members and
whoops, sorry aliases using
under score capital interview is
zip view of view types dot.
OK, so that is this interview
exposition only.
And then coming down, unique
counteracts, which we'll use
someday movable box, our helper
machinery templated on funk,
this one called under score
capital function. OK and then
we've got the interview named
under score Capital ZIP, OK.
And then.
We've got these separator and
the Sentinel. I think these are
actually the same names as in
the others.
But they're actually in the
standard.
That's great.
OK, so template and we'll const
using under score capital zip
erator is an iterator, T maybe
Const is const interview and
then template on bool is Const.
Still ugly Sentinel as the
Sentinel test of maybe consists
const interview. OK good.
And then.
We've got the template boys
Const. Our category base that's
going to help with getting piped
defs. I guess this is
specialized specialized below.
Iterator. Sorry, I'm scanning
below. Here's a Sentinel.
Ah, do we ever specialize? OK.
Let's see, where do we
specialize? Ohh no, this
specialization is immediately
below. Yay reading
comprehension. I was just like I
was expecting something small.
And so when I saw this big
thing, my eyes just glazed right
over it. OK, so we got category
base. We'll see what this
machine is doing. This is going
to be needed for presumably the
iterator. Yes, the iterator. OK.
So let's start reviewing the
iterator.
Down here.
OK, so template on both Const.
Is it transform view iterator?
OK.
And then iterator category is
the thing that's not always
present.
OK, here we go. The member
Typedef name iterator category
is defined if and only if it
models forward range, so.
The specialization.
On template Bullis constant
requires forward range.
Umm, the base scrolling up which
is maybe Const interview? Maybe
Conn's interview OK.
So when that's met, then we have
the iterator category, so that's
why I'm doing here.
OK, let me go down Umm so base
models forward range which it
does and in that case it or
categories defined as follows.
OK so we've got this here.
Umm using iterator category, so
this is.
Wow. Uh, that's a big Lambda
using iterator categories. The
decal type of an immediate
invocation of this puppy.
Praise print, print.
So we're doing a lot of
computation here. This looks
horrible, but it would have been
way, way more horrible without
lambdas and decltype, and if
constexpr. So this is actually
not as bad as it seems.
And it's mapping all these
bullet points, hopefully pretty
straightforwardly. OK, we have a
Lambda.
The no except here is kind of
unnecessary because it's the
type computation, but it's not
wrong, so that's fine.
Let's see if. OK, so invoke T
under score cabinet. Invoke T is
the invoke result of maybe Const
Const F ref.
Invoked on a range reference T
maybe cons is Conn's view types
dot.
OK, here's here's one of what
I'm checking for is. Is there
any obnoxious repetition that
could be extracted out? There's
a little bit.
And this may be const. Ohh no,
it's it's not really
extractable. This is being pack
expanded because there's a whole
bunch of you types we need to
spam out range reference key of
maybe Const is view 0, maybe
Const is Const view one blah
blah blah over and over. This
one is expanding something
completely different derived
from and dot dot dot so there's
no extraction possible with like
a type def. That's best we can
do.
With without like an alias
template.
OK, so that's good. If that
thing is OK, we've got that
invoke result.
If it is not a reference, not is
reference V.
Then the iterator category this
Lambda is going to return input
iterator tag OK if constexpr,
else otherwise. So this is the
else branch.
Umm.
We're going to have a context
for auto. We've got a nested
Lambda here, and then we're
going to do a bunch of stuff.
Interesting.
And we're feeding it an explicit
template argument rather than
tag dispatch.
Yeah, it's it's horrible and
syntax, but it's reasonable. OK,
so let's seize denote the packet
types, iterator traits blah.
OK, so this is asking.
That's this thing iterator
traits of iterator T. Maybe
Const is const of U types.
OK.
So seizes that. Oh, and we need
the iterator category, so type
name iterator category. So this
is the C.
Which we can't just extract as
at the pack. So this is saying
concepts per auto, under score,
capital check, tag type closure
where Lambda taking template on
a tape name tag type.
Conventionally we always say
class here, but explicit
template parameters for lambdas
are so novel. I don't you know
if we have any of the product
code.
I personally prefer type name.
We just tried to enforce code
conventions. Do we have any
lambdas?
Should this nested landed?
Should this nested land to be a
variable template instead?
It feels like it could OK, we
only have one and it's in the,
UM, one occurrence of
tightening. At least it's in the
test. It's a good question
whether it could be V elsewhere.
We have used class. OK, so I
think stylistically asked for
class, but you've got the better
question rather than my silly
syntax level question. Could
this be a variable template?
The pencil.
In which case we wouldn't need
this horribleness.
Umm, but we left this out.
Yeah, that, that's.
Yeah.
The explicit template argument
list for a Lambda is just a
Every.
horrible.
It's.
Yeah, it's syntactically horror.
I mean, it's a very clever
solution. So like this is and it
it's definitely it's translating
the machinery in the standard
well, so no complaints there.
But if we could simplify it,
that would be even better.
What does this depend on in the
the usual sense, the word we
care about, we've already got
the is Const. We've got the view
types.
Umm. If we made it a variable
template?
The enclosing Lambda is not
generic, so it's not dependent
on any template parameters of
that Banta.
It's the best the class, the
class template arguments and
Yeah, good point.
Yeah.
whatever the internal.
There is constant.
And if you're types out here.
Manda template.
Yeah, with the.
So it could be a static
constexpr class memory variable
template.
Yeah. OK.
But rather than completely top
level being static, constexpr be
good and this is C plus latest
so we don't need to worry about
Clr pure, which is really really
hates variable templates.
Umm, so I think that would be
good.
How then would there be any
other robots to simplifying
this? It would be you've got
your V here templated on the tag
type.
And it would just be a bull that
would be this. It would need to
return.
And then we would if constexpr
Brit.
Yeah, yeah, I think it would be
strictly simpler, because mainly
we'd be getting rid of this bit
and the syntax involved invoking
it and we wouldn't need to
return, it would just be equals
blah. We might still need to
suppress clang format, but it
should generally be good. OK, so
let's come on this.
OK.
Thinking should we have a
separate syntax in a PIC and a
style in the pick? I'll say
syntax nitpick first just on
this line syntax nitpick.
Umm, this says I'm type name,
but we conventionally say.
Class in product code.
OK. And then the actual much
more important semantic nitpick
or not really semantic, it's
more like implementation style.
This.
Is correct.
And a fairly straightforward
transformation of the standard
ease.
Umm.
But passing on.
Explicit template argument to a
Lambda is.
Relatively unusual.
And.
Verbose.
As all of the call sites below
need template disambiguator.
Umm.
I'm eating you, Casey. No, it's
uh. There we go at Casey Carter.
At Casey, Carter would have said
her rific instead of unusual and
Observed.
ferbus, but your mileage may
vary.
Or horrific.
Yeah.
Observed having too much fun
here that this could instead be
written as a static constexpr
variable template within the
scope of.
Category based is Const.
Yeah, because we should just be
able to.
Put it like right before or no,
it's got to be before the
iterator category because this
is the type def.
Umm, within this scope of
category based cons, would this
Lambda then need to?
But you need to capture it. I
sure hope not.
Because we're within a Lambda
invocation here.
Capture I'd a variable template,
no?
If we had a static.
OK, because it's not a local
variable, OK.
Well, yeah, yeah, it's not a
functional look. We can't
capture anything that's not a
function local anyway.
OK, OK, I I forget how this
language works. There's there's
too many things.
Yeah. Thank you for explaining.
Uh, yeah, I know. It's just
You have the silly language.
like, you know, 3000 something,
pages of standardese all crammed
in my brain. OK, so stay at
constexpr within the scope scope
of category based is Const.
I'm then.
Let's say static constexpr bool.
Umm. Then the definition
wouldn't need.
Return instead. It would simply
provide the value of the bool.
As it's initializer.
And the usages below.
Wouldn't need.
Template operator prinn pren.
Like this?
The rest of the code.
Would remain.
Basically.
Unchanged. OK. Uh has a sound.
This is correct and a fairly
straightforward transformation
of the standard ease.
I do want to make clear that
this is uh, up at a hard ice cat
here.
Because I like straightforward
transformations otherwise, then
my brain has to work figuring
out what's going on here. This
is correct and a fairly
straightforward transformation
of the standardized cat, but
passing an explicit template
argument to a Lambda is
relatively unusual and verbose
is all the call types below need
template disambiguator Casey,
who created characterized this
as horrific, observed that this
could instead be written as a
static constexpr bool variable
template within the scope of
category basis Const. Then the
definition would need return.
Instead, it would simply provide
the value of the bool as its
initializer.
And the usages below wouldn't
need template operator print
print the rest of the code would
remain basically unchanged. OK.
OK, so derive from blah random
access or tag. This is what this
is doing 3 different times. I do
appreciate that it's all been
lifted out.
OK so.
If Constexpr check for random
access iterator tag. Oh, that's
just what this is doing, ran it,
ran it, bite it, bite it,
forward it, forward it,
otherwise input so ran it, ran
it, bite it, bite it for it,
forward it, otherwise import
error tag. OK, bunch of braces.
OK, good. So that's all this
stuff.
OK, then we've got. What is this
the non constrained one? No,
this is the one that's going to
use the category base. So
category based only provides
iterator category conditionally.
Everything else is extracted
down here.
OK, so let's go down here.
OK, ranges. This is the zip
transform view iterator, so
that's what we're looking at
here. Template will under score
kept is cons class, under score
cap iterator drives publicly
from category basis, cons to
private stuff we grant
friendship.
To our parents of transform
view.
We're just correct. Parent needs
friendship in order to access.
Our data Members and other stuff
here, but this can access
private members of the parent
just fine because it's a member
like any other. OK?
Then some typedefs using parent
tea is maybe Const is const for
zip transform view using base T
is maybe Const interview.
Parents Starr or parent star
under score kept parent is null
putter.
And then.
Coming out no unique address
because the pointer is always
going to occupy memory. Zip
erator is Const under score kept
inner. OK, that's all good.
And then we have a constructor.
Constexpr iterator constructor.
Taking apparently ref under
parent under.
And then a zipper rator is
const.
Inner.
OK, we don't have to type for
that and that's under inner
owner, OK.
And then we are conditionally
noexcept strengthen because it
appears in the standard. Because
of this constructor signature
appears in the standard. We're
no except when and here I'm
checking for two noexcept, which
there aren't. Good is no throw
move constructible V zip reader
is const because we're moving
that.
Said parent to be tested at
Arsov. This thing that we passed
by reference set inner to be a
stood move of under inner honor.
OK, public stuff.
OK.
So we've got the iterator
category provided by the base,
not always present in the public
section.
Using iterator concept is type
name. Zip erator is Const
iterator concept OK.
Using value type remove C VFT
invoke result T maybe Const is
Const. Funk Ref Ranger reference
T maybe Const is Const view
types dot OK.
I'm not even selecting taxes
good enough.
Using difference type is range
difference T based T OK that's
good.
Iterator prinn pren.
OK, this is getting a no except.
But the standard just says
default.
I wonder if this is actually
necessary.
It feels like it shouldn't.
Shouldn't be. I feel like we
should just say what the
standard says, just default it.
There's no reason to like have
an error if this thing's wrong,
because it's always gonna be
right. If we've got it correct.
No, except is no third defect
extractable V. Zip rater is
const. That's the only thing
that could fail.
Umm, this is verbose enough that
I think I'm going to ask for the
no except to be removed.
It is. I mean it's correct and
it's even not strengthening. It
does match the standard, but.
I think we should just say
default.
All this is correct. I think
that's simply omitting the.
No, except.
Specification.
Would be reasonable.
As.
It exactly matches what the
compiler will generate and the
standard simply depicts.
Copy paste. Yep, I'm not in
selection.
Yeah, this thing.
OK, how's it look?
Back to highlight, while this is
correct, I think that simply
omitting the no excess
specification would be excuse
me. While this is correct, I
think that simply emitting the
no excess specification would be
reasonable as it exactly matches
what the compiler will generate
and the standard simply depicts
Iterator Prinn Pren is default.
OK.
Umm, still public stuff. We have
a constexpr constructor iterator
from iterator not is Const. I is
becoming under score kept RSS.
We have a strengthening, so this
is no except when is nothrow
convertible V.
From.
Zipper rator of false.
To zip rator is const.
That's interesting.
This is being written in a
dependent way, which is probably
good so that it's delayed until
we actually instantiate this
thing.
This requires this count, so we
know we are Const. Our source is
non consumer. Adding constants
to it. So convertible from non
cons to us and we know where
Const OK so that is the correct
direction, it's not reversed.
Umm. OK. So again we watching
the standard requires is const
and convertible 2 zip, rater
false, zip, rater Const OK.
That's why it's written that
way. The standard has this zip
rater falls, zip raters const
and then the no except matches
that but changes the concept
convertible to to is no throw.
Convertible V type track which
is good.
And then construct. This is not
super surprising down here,
parent.
Uh RHS parent?
For storing pointers, so we
don't need this address of stuff
here and then inner stood move
art to center. OK good.
OK then.
Ah, it's gonna hear. No, that
was the that was different.
One even looking at here why?
Where did this come from? Oh,
no. This was the this one. OK.
This is the address of. I'm
getting confused. This is the
address of.
Umm, here's the conversion.
The conversion simply says
parent type parent innertube
Venner OK.
OK, back In Sync. Now operator
dref, that's up here.
So we're adding notice card
because DRF is always notice
card constexpr. Decltype auto
offer draft Const no except. See
below. Let's check that.
Ah Umm.
Umm, the exact specification is
equivalent to no except horrible
thing.
But that's just the body.
Except invoke.
Yeah, it's literally just the
body, O contrino, except if no
except stood apply, dereference,
closure, prinn, pren it. OK,
that's fine. I really wish we
had no except auto returns to
deeply exact same thing.
Yeah, for everything there,
invoke. I guess that we're going
to see what the.
He reference closure has is up
below.
Excuse me. Yeah, it's below.
Here's this.
Horrible Empire thing, OK?
Here and funny. OK, that's good.
Let's go back.
Umm here.
OK, that's looking good.
OK, more iterator operations.
UM, just looking at the
definitions here rather than
the.
Passed snaps and I'll go back up
and highlight that constexpr
here not nodiscard constexpr
iterator ref operator plus plus
strengthening to be no except
when no except plus a Sinner OK.
Uh also center turned off this.
I'm I'm look at my brain is
short circuiting cause I'm
seeing these braces on their own
line. I'm like oh, that should
be a slash star rather than
slash slash so that the brace
can go on the right line.
I'm going to grudgingly refrain
commenting about that. Plus the
Sinner return to your for this.
Trying to be a little bit less
into picky in the new year.
Uh. Constexpr void whoops.
Operator plus int. Again
strengthening, no, except if no
except.
Plus plus this is void, so guess
expert void operator plus
assent. We're no exceptive
noexcept, can we say plus plus
to deco Val iterator ref,
because we can't easily say this
here.
I vaguely recall this is like
subject to some compiler bug or
something, but wait, this is
weird. Let's even going on here
cuz.
This says no except plus plus
zero for this.
So why are these different? I
would I would understand if one
couldn't say it, but the other
that's weird.
They should really be identical.
Yeah, I'm gonna come about this.
They are the same expression,
it's just this once constrained.
Why?
That neither a template, this
one is constrained but.
Yeah. OK. Comment.
See uh copy this inner bit prime
prime paren.
This says blah, but the next
overload says.
Law.
Could the former?
Do the.
Or could we use? Or could we
avoid? I wanna be unambiguous
deco Val for both.
OK, this says no except plus
plus Taco Bell stuff, but the
next overload says no except
plus plus dear. If this, could
we avoid equal for both?
So this one just says plus
posterior for this. OK. Next
again no, no discard constexpr
return iterator by value. I'll
plus percent strengthening.
We're noexcept when is no throw
compostable V iterator because
we got a return ourselves and no
except plus to your for this
strengthened requires support
range of base T effects
equivalent 2.
Auto temp is due for this.
Increment.
Return temp.
There's kind of a spurious new
line there.
I will refrain.
Ah, constexpr or iterator ref.
Uh, minus minus.
Strengthening, no, except if no
except.
3 decater inner OK.
Strengthened.
Requires bidirectional Orange
base predict inner return to
your this OK, that's good.
OK, I can't resist. I got a
comment about this new line.
It's driving me nuts.
And in fact.
Unnecessary new line here
occurs.
Below popping though I'll
highlight this occurs below and.
I'll admit it's a Megan epic.
Making it pick unnecessary new
line here occurs below an
operator minus mice and.
OK, very, very necessary going
back.
This is minus min requires by
range base the post version this
one OK again no nodiscard const
expert iterator.
At minus minus int.
Strengthening noexcept one is no
through complex structural V
iterator and no except minus
minus drew for this strengthened
OK bidirectional, Orange base
auto under score capital temp is
this predict this?
Return the temp OK.
Now we're up to plus SQL. Still
no no discard constexpr
iterator, Ralph Upper SQL Const.
Good difference. Type off. We're
no, except if this is no, except
inner plus SQL auth. OK, we're
turning reference that is also
strengthened requires random
access range based T effects
equivalent to inner plus equal
auth return to you for this.
OK, next Council expert iterator
ref. Minus equal const.
Difference type off. No, except
if no except inner minus SQL off
strengthened. Still random
access range effects equivalent
to enter minus SQL auth. Turn
dear for this. OK, I don't see
any minus or plus getting
swapped here.
OK, now we're back to the land
of notice car because your
square bracketing, so notice
card, constexpr, decltype, auto,
opera square bracket take a
const difference type where.
Where const. We're
strengthening. No accepted. No
except stood apply random
access. Closure. Where? In her
current matching of the body.
Good. Requires random access
range.
Affects equivalent to. We've
seen that this random access
closure.
Is, I guess, going to be similar
to the dereference closure
thing. It's going to handle
this, but we'll come back and
when we find that definition,
we'll look at it.
OK, then we got equals. So
friend Nodiscard friend.
Umm constexpr bool operator
equal cons iterator FLHS
considerato FRHS?
We are strengthening no
exceptive noexcept le Center is
our center, OK requires a
quality comparable zip erator
Const.
Interesting.
Aren't we in separator?
Why are we not using the
injected class name here?
Ohh no we're.
Or iterator here.
Zip Arator is the specific type
dev of which one?
Oh, no zip Raiders. The template
here. Look, I'm getting
confused. UM.
The separators the template here
it says get the iterator from
the interview ohh the the
original iterator, not the zip
transform iterator.
OK.
OK, so there is no injected
class name, we're the iterator,
but we got a phrased in terms of
the quality comparable of the
underlying separator. OK, too
many iterators going back here.
So matches requires a quality
comparable zipper reader is
constant. OK, so there's no
concern of an injected class
name. Good.
Definition. Yep, X interop
winner. OK, that's good. LHHS is
equal to Rohs. No swapping or
anything.
Excuse me, Nodiscard friend
comes expert auto opera
spaceship considerato FLHS
considerato FRHS.
No, except if no except
strengthening Lehner spaceship
Rohner priors. Our anaxes range
based T.
Turned Ally just in her
spaceship. Archer center. OK,
good, that's all this.
And we got some pluses.
Again returning by value, so no
discard friend.
Uh constexpr iterator operator.
Plus consider a refl AHS.
Const difference type RHS Reno
Exceptive no except match the
body construct iterator brace
from DFL parent LHS enter pasari
just brace strengthened requires
random access range.
Return iterator deaf parent I
enter plus N Yep, that's exactly
right. And the next one is the
same, except things have been
swapped around. So nodiscard
friend constexpr iterator
operator plus Const difference
type lehs, const, iterator ref.
Rohs no except if no except swap
L&R exactly L to RR to LL
quiz random access range
iterator. This matches OK good.
That's that's this getting close
to the end of the iterator.
Umm nodiscard friend constexpr
iterator operator minus cons
iterator ref LHHS cons
difference type Rohs.
Yep.
Noexcept if no except
strengthening iterator deaf
parent I just enter minus Rohs.
Here I make sure we're not copy
pasting stuff wrongly requires a
random access range. Yep, that's
all good.
OK. And then read something so
horrible clang format needed to
be suppressed.
Interesting. I wouldn't expect
this to need it.
Maybe it really didn't like
this. That's really surprising.
Usually clang format, it's
pretty good about this now.
I won't comment. I assume there
was a reason for this.
OK.
So notice card friend.
Constexpr difference type
operator minus. Consider refl us
consider refr us.
You accept if noexcept elhs
inner minus Rohner correct order
strengthened requires so I
Sentinel 4 ZIP reader is con zip
reader is const.
OK, does this default?
Can you provide just one
argument here? And I know it's
exactly what the standard says.
I thought there was like a
default.
Or is it?
I don't believe so.
Where is the definition OK?
Maybe I'm maybe I'm
misremembering. I guess it would
say concept somewhere. Usages.
Should be an extra utility.
Yeah, there we go.
OK, there's no default. It's
just.
It's an internal.
Seeing it OK.
OK, so we got to pass them both
try and clang format L just
enter minus R Just center. OK,
that's all the operators. Then
we got some helpers.
So private helper.
We've got a dereference closure
and then a random access
closure. So let's scroll up to
the dereference.
So notice scared on the helper.
Constexpr auto under score
chapter dereference closure.
This is excuse me constant and
no except.
Why is it no except because
we're simply capturing at this
pointer? OK, so this says
return. I'm here return capture
this.
Take Const auto ref dot iters.
And have some noexcept stuff
aerodeck type auto the no except
to say no except if no except
stood invoked your parent
function do your filters dot so
it matches the body.
Umm. And then return invoke dear
parent fun.
Derek fitters dot.
On intercurrent. OK, so
dereference closures, good
random access closure is on the
square bracket.
So notice carcass expert auto
random access closure take a
const difference type where
Const noexcept.
OK, we are capturing the this
pointer. We're capturing where
which is just a different types.
That's fine. It could be no
except template and unclass this
time iterator types.
Replacing eyes, pick Const
iterator types ref dot iters.
So no, except strengthening and
then aerodeck type auto anodes
horribly wrapped on GitHub here.
We're no exceptive, no, except
the should match. The body stood
invoked your current function it
or static cast it are
difference. Tea if we're OK,
that's all good.
As this matches dear of parent
fan hitters of.
OK, uh, Tyler has replaced this
interference paren with the
static cast. Very much
appreciate it.
Because we do not like our C
style or functional style C
semantics casts. OK, that's
perfect.
OK, that's the end of.
The iterator OK, the Sentinel.
OK, we've got a comment here
that.
Sure looks like it's going to
need to be become a transition.
So there's a Sentinel. Here's a
Sentinel. Same template stuff.
Here's a Sentinel. OK, template
bool under score kept is Conn's
class. under score kept Sentinel
private stuff. Grant friendship
does it transform. View our
parent. OK, so this comment
says, so here's an interesting
MSVC bug we'll come eye is bug.
We usually avoid saying bug in
our product code if we have
signal operator minus return
range difference team maybe
cons.
Iterator const.
There's iterator comes coming
from.
Oh, it's it's templated here.
Interview directly as suggested
in the CPP standard, ADL does
not seem to find the function
test suite and the program fails
to compile. This does not seem
to happen with client. OK, this
needs to be reported as a bug.
This should be reported.
As an MSVC bug.
And then this.
So should be marked as
transition.
Citing the bug number we
conventionally.
Uh, avoid a literally saying bug
in the product code.
I'm trying to think do we
actually have? I'm curious, do
we actually have any occurrences
where we violated that role at
least in ink? Do we ever say
bug?
We do say compiler bug
workaround for the vitar disc
stuff.
Which is a little bit more
direct than we usually do.
That that was my fault too. I
did that, Victor, this stuff,
this PMD, this would be an
internal interesting. This
should if it's a bug in invoke.
This should really be an STL
internal static invoke or sorry
STL internal static assert.
Yeah, I think that probably
predates the existence of STL
The probably does.
internal static is there.
Yeah, I'll record it too. I'll
clean this up later. Um.
Should be. We're finding all
these great things to clean up
internal static cert and then
this is just a comment saying
this should work. Otherwise
there's a bug. So OK, so we do
generally avoid saying bug.
OK, let's see.
If this works with Clang, what
is actually being worked around
here? If we have minus return
range difference T?
OK. So Tyler is introducing an
alias template to avoid
literally saying range
difference T there.
So the Sentinel operator minus
for claying could do the right
thing.
Is it worth guarding the
workaround with if and deaf?
Or should we just always use the
workaround?
If it seems like could be
reasonable always, it's used
twice. If we guarded both, that
would be annoying. I'm OK with
always using the workaround
until we got to get rid of it.
Umm.
Yeah.
The little bit annoying when we
have something marked as
transition without a clear
reminder of what to do when it
goes away.
Umm, but I think it would be
fine. We'll we'll be able to
backtrack and figure out what
happened here. This should be
reported as an MSVC bug and then
this code should be marked as
transition citing the bug
number. We conventionally avoid
literally saying bug in the
product code on actually with
only a few exceptions.
OK.
This is extracted template on
bool, under score kept iterator,
cons using iterator. Sentinel
difference type is range
difference, team maybe Const
iterator, Const interview. OK,
so here's our data Member no
unique address which is maybe
not super useful when we only
have one day to remember. I
forget the rules but no unique
address. We got. The Sentinel is
Const inner.
And then we are still in the
private section.
We have a const expert explicit.
Under score capital Sentinel.
Construct from a Sentinel is
const under inner honor
strengthening. We're no
acceptive is no through copy
constructible. V Sentinels
const.
Interesting that we don't bother
moving it exposition only.
Umm, that's what the standard
depicts. So OK.
Caused the standard holes too.
Then oops, I lost my place.
There's a converting constructor
here.
No, sorry. That's why we just
reviewed losing my place. This
one here template on Bool, under
score kept iterator cons where
nodiscard helper.
We are static, we're constexpr.
We return Const auto ref.
Or called get iterator zipper
orator.
We take Const iterator,
iterator, concrete ITER.
We can't because already static,
but we're no except.
And we we returned refs. That's
fine. Umm, return. Enter, enter.
Because we were granted
friendship.
Is that true?
We're reaching into the iterator
class.
And because we are a member of.
The parents have transform view.
We have the same access rights
as any other member. The
iterator granted friendship to
the parent and thus the Sentinel
can access it. OK, that's good.
So we have the minimum amount of
friendship needed.
OK, so public matching this
public Sentinel, again, the same
concern about the No, except
I'll go back and edit the
comment that it also applies to
Sentinel.
Rather than having to comments
or is it here? Oh, I didn't have
this one. I hate it when I do
that.
OK.
Occurs below 4 Sentinel.
OK, while this is cracked,
simply admitting the no access
specification will be reasonable
occurs below for Sentinel. OK
now I'm paranoid and I wonder if
I didn't submit anything else.
Does anything say add review no
perfect OK resuming.
Here.
OK, so we are hopefully getting
close to the end of the product
code.
Constexpr excuse me, I'm
constexpr sentinal taking a
Sentinel of not Const. I does
now under score kept archs OK.
We're strengthened. So no,
except strengthened when is no
through convertible V zentyal
false to Sentinel. Const very
much like the Iterator 1
requires Const and convertible
tools from Sentinel Falls to
Sentinels. Const.
Uh construct inner withstood
move RHS inner good got all the
qualification and then?
OK. Wow, I really wonder how
Clang format is mangling this.
Maybe it doesn't like the
noexcept?
Template unbook iterator Const
OK, that's standing in for other
Const here requires Sentinel
four. Sentinel is const zipper
orator.
Other const. OK, let's make sure
we didn't get swapped zenel
Const is Sentinel is const zip
rate or other Const zip, rater
iterator cons OK.
And if Clang format where
Nodiscard friend expert bowl up
equal counts iterator of
Iterator Const as other cons
refl AHS.
Constant nor FRS.
Or strength that no septic. No.
Except can we say get iterator
separator lehs is our center OK.
Uh and?
And.
That's this. OK, we need that.
This helper function.
Uh, we need the helper function
because this is a friend and we
haven't granted access to the
friend, so we've got to do this
like chain of helpers to get to
the guts. OK, so that's good.
Um, same deal here. In fact, it
should look very similar.
This is for the minus. Wait,
where are we? We just did the
equal. Now in one of the
minuses.
OK.
So template bool Iterator Const
requires High Sentinel 4 xenel
is const matching, zenel, Const,
zip, rater iterator Const which
zip rater other Const notice
card friend Constexpr.
Uh, here's that work round.
Iterator Sentinel difference
type iterator constant standing
in for range difference T. Maybe
consider constant review. OK
yeah.
Clang format off operator minus
tank considerate or of iterator
cons reflexus concentr chess or
strengthened no, except if no
except same body with the minus
clang format on return. Yep,
that's this.
And then we've got it reversed.
OK, so should be exactly the
same except stuff as reversed.
Yep, that's good iterator Const
off on.
Operator minus. OK, so we have
consentual, Raph. That's not
LHS. Const, iterator, iterator.
Const graph. That's rohs. No
exceptive. No except.
LHHS inner minus get iterator,
zip, writer of Rohs and this
matches good.
OK. That is the Sentinel.
Umm, now popping back up to the
transform transform view. So
we've got all this.
Yeah, we got the sun all.
We've got this for sure. Uh, all
the iterators stuff.
OK. And uh, yeah, these were all
the declarations of the stuff we
reviewed.
In the iterator.
Can we get these?
Sorry, my brain is wondering if
we got those pluses. I don't
remember the pluses. If I
already forgotten.
Yeah, we we got them all. We
have the plus, we got the plus
all the we got the minus. OK, I
totally. I totally forgot that.
Yep, all these friends. Yep,
looks good.
OK, so we're here.
At the end of the Sentinel
looking at.
Is a no except.
And we have that probably
because it's used for
strengthening, OK.
And so this is actually a
variable template, so that's
nice expressed as a Lambda
template bool. under score kept
is Const, static constexpr bool,
under score kept is and no
except is a Lambda.
That is itself noexcept.
Which I think we.
Do no, no, we don't need. We
don't technically need it here.
But again, it's fine if
constexpr per.
OK. That's interesting. We
should look at the definition of
end. That's this. Sorry for
screwing around so fast and
here.
Umm so if constexpr.
We want to know common range of
interview which is maybe
conscious Const interview.
Then return noexcept. Can we
make an iterator?
Is const.
OK, so this is handling both
simultaneously. That's
interesting. This and this.
And we're saying.
OK, so that's so I'm backing up
template is Const. Is then
noexcept Lambda if constexpr. OK
so common range.
Of either interview or constant
interview, and that's handled by
maybe constant is const
interview OK then return. No.
Except can we make an iterator
false or true? That is iterator
is const from this and zip and
that's the same so.
The this drew for this is stood
decal Val of maybe Cons is Khan
zip transform view ref.
OK, it's got to be a null value
and then zip end is stood
equivale. Maybe Constance
interview RAF.
.net.
OK.
Otherwise, we're not coming
range.
So that's these two.
Return.
And if concepts were else OK,
return noexcept of you can make
a Sentinel of false or true.
That's his const from zip end.
That's decadal maybe consist
const interview ref. Yep.
So a little bit of duplication
here. Maybe this could be
extracted out, but this is fine.
Yeah, well, my heuristic is
something's repeated three
times. This should probably be
extracted, but twice is fine.
OK, so that handles the noexcept
for end and then static
constexpr bool which is not
templated at all. under score
capital enable Const begin end
is.
Looks like the this. Yeah, this
is. This is exactly matching. So
if we have a range of constant
or view and regular invocable
Const FFRF range reference T
Const view types dot then we can
enable Const begin it. OK.
OK, so we've got the iterator.
We got the Sentinel. We are now
doing public stuff. Uh, zip,
transform, view, print, run.
Again, we've got a default here
that has an explicit noexcept.
This is just saying movable box
and interview I I'm gonna extend
the comment cause I think that
should be applied here too.
That's got a. Here we go.
Chris Bluffer signal and the
transform view.
But no excessive vestigation.
OK.
I sat long. We looked at this.
Ah, the transform view. OK
defaulted.
Defaulted.
OK.
We're at a constructor. Uh,
constexpr, explicit, zip
transform view construct from F
fun that's funk under function
under views dot views.
View types dot views.
OK, does this shadow anything?
I thought we had to view
somewhere.
Scroll way way way up.
That's the iterator.
OK, we only have function in
zip.
It was the zip view that had the
views. Yeah. So we only have
function in zip, so no ambiguity
here. We're good. OK, down down.
Down to Nope, not far enough.
Here we go.
Umm view types views OK.
Uh, strengthening. We're no
except if.
We need.
Constructing the function with
an in place so is no throw move
constructible V movable box
funk.
This is asking is the entire
movable box move constructible,
but we're constructing one of
them from move function.
Is this necessary? Could we
simply say is no term move
constructible V funk?
I gotta look at what the types
are.
That's the iterator.
Function is a movable box of
funk.
OK.
I think I'm gonna need to look
at the definition.
I wouldn't be concerned if this
matched what we're doing, what
we're calling the in place
constructor of of the movable
box. So.
Let's go look at what the move
blocks does. Move a bowl box.
We're go.
Simplified optional. So if you
are a in place constructor from
a bunch of types, we're
strengthened to be is nothrow
constructible on that type from
types, because we're just going
to construct the thing.
If you try to move it.
Uh, do we have that
strengthened?
We ask it if it's trivially
moved. Ohh, we ask if it's
trivially move constructible.
That's a different question than
an initial construction.
Oh, no, sorry, this is
overloaded.
Oh oh, it's not no, except if
it's nontrivial. We always do
work and we don't strengthen
this.
It's interesting that this was
not strengthened. OK, so I think
I think I've actually found a a
minor bug in the the noexcept
strengthening here.
Because asking is the movable
that is the movable box no to
our move constructible.
We'll say true if it's trivially
move constructible, but straight
up false if it's not trivially
moved constructible, even if
it's no except.
And we're not actually moving
the thing at all here, OK, so.
This is boats. Minor bogus like
2 out of 10 bogus. Where was I
looking? I was looking at this.
We're in ranges, movable box, OK
time to quote.
STL Inc.
Ranges.
The biggest challenge I would
say one of the biggest
challenges in Marian code is
sitting through, you know, 400
lines of incredibly repetitive
and every character counts,
review and then keeping enough
attention so that you actually
notice the one bit always near
the end, usually where something
is a little bit questionable.
OK, where's that movable box?
There are other skills needed,
but this is an underappreciated
one I think. OK, hit why to get
permalink movable box.
I'll probably wanna quote both.
Yeah. So let me duplicate the
first one or the one of them.
I'm gonna want to quote is this
because this is what we're
actually doing.
And then then oops, movable box.
Come on. Here. Got. Here we go.
It's the move. See door.
That's this thing.
I'll drop the clay from it off,
move seed, or is trivially
nontrivial here.
OK, so this.
OK, going back to zip transform
view, here we go. So this is
constructing function from in
place move function.
This one I think is fine. The
the zip part because that's
saying.
I want to make sure if I come in
about a bug in one member that
I'm not missing another bug
lurking in the second member
construct. The zip so is no hero
constructible. The interview?
That's the zip from Studmire
views. That is, take the view
types.
Remove reference key from them
and then add ref ref OK that's
right. So it's this part that is
not right. OK, I wanna comment
on.
Maybe just this now I wanna get
that. No, except in there.
Otherwise it'll look weird. OK.
Ah, I specifically think this is
wrong.
This says.
In the stirring, thinned new
accept specification, but we
aren't.
Move constructing a.
Movable box.
Here.
Instead.
Where using its.
In.
Place.
Constructor.
Are actually want this one
quoted, I'll quote them in
order. Oh, I think that was the
one that I had.
Umm.
Which directly constructs the
stored type. I'll say that.
Which?
Directly directory directly
constructs.
Be stored type.
And.
Is accordingly.
Strengthened.
Umm, I think.
It would.
Miller, both both options then
mention which one I prefer. I
either the.
Exception specification here
should exactly match the.
Mem.
Initializer list by saying.
Is it's actually just this.
Uh, double checking before I
copy paste is no through
constructible V.
From and then make sure we copy
the right one movable box funk.
From and then when we move
function.
That would be.
Funk is an object type, right?
And I hope it's not a reference
type.
I think we can just say funk
here.
Do we have any constraints on
this thing?
Sorry for scrolling.
Ohh template move constructible
funk.
I forget if that. Oh, no, here
we go. Is object VC fund. So
it's an object type. There's no
sneaky references. Great.
Because if I say.
Funk. And if it could be a
reference that has interesting
effects for type traits, but if
lunch is an guaranteed object
type then just saying funk means
that it's an R value. Boy, I
wanna make this bigger, OK.
Ah, there we go. So is no throw
constructible V the thing we're
constructing is the function.
That is a.
That confusingly, actually
function is a movable box, but
under function under is a funk.
It's not wrong I think.
Yeah, correct. Move a box funk
function. OK, so the types are
different even though they only
different under score. Going
back down is another constructiv
movable box to funk from funk.
That.
Umm.
Or it should?
Take a shortcut.
And.
Match or say.
Shortcut and depict the ultimate
construction, the ultimate
construction being performed.
And that is, that's just a move
construction of the object type
is no throw move constructible
funk.
So that would be this, which was
in Ridgely intended.
Of the funk.
OK. Is that right?
I'll, I'll provide it. All is
not move start funk.
I prefer this.
And then I'll mention that this
is actually correctness such
issue.
This is actually a minor.
Correctness issue.
Are.
This is actually, I'll just say
minor issue.
Not purely cosmetic as movable.
Boxes move constructor is not.
Always strengthened according to
what it does.
OK, complicated comment. Let's
make sure I didn't script
anything here.
Uh, OK, so.
This says and checking this one.
Is no through move constructible
V movable box funk in the
strengthen Noexcept
specification, but we aren't
move constructing a movable box
here.
Move constructible with
constructing with box. Yes.
Instead we're using its in place
constructor which directly
constructs the store type and is
accordingly strengthened quoting
movable box and place T
constructor strengthened OK,
either the exception
specification here should
exactly match the list by
saying.
Is no through Constructable V
our movable box funk.
From the funk R value.
Actually, that doesn't even
exactly match. Whoo, yeah,
really doesn't know I screwed
that up. It's really is no
structural be moving box funk.
And then the in place thing. And
then this, I guess we would need
to stay in place. T technically
this is an lvalue, but we can
kind of take a shortcut and say
in place TR value.
I'll simplify this. I'll I'll
make it, say, depict the
ultimate construction. This is
actually a minor issue, not
purely cosmetic. Is movable
walks, is move. Constructor is
not always strengthened
according to what it does.
Here's the move constructors.
This one is clearly not
strengthened. OK, so let's go
fix this bit about the ultimate
construction.
Umm.
Which would be somewhat annoying
as we'd need to mention the
thing in place T as well.
OK, let's just gloss over the
annoying thing that I don't
actually want to suggest here.
Go either the accession
specification here should
exactly match the initializer
list, which would be somewhat
annoying as we need to mention
in place T2 or it should take a
shortcut and pick the ultimate
construction being performed.
Is no throw move constructible V
funk, because we're ultimately
moving the function which is
funk. I prefer this. OK good.
OK, getting close to the end. We
made the comment on the zip
transform view constructor. Then
we got some beginning size and
maybe a deduction guide. OK.
OK. And this is fairly simple
because stuff has already been
lifted out. We have got missing
notice cards.
All they should be notice, card
begin and size.
Yeah.
Begin outsize.
All of the overloads of begin.
And.
And size.
Should be marked no discard.
All the overloads of begin and
inside should be marked notice
card OK.
O missing notice card constexpr
auto begin strengthening. We are
no exceptive. No except.
Matching the body construct
iterator falls from deer for
this zip. Again, strengthened
return iterator false dear. If
this tip again.
And constexpr emitting those car
because we already commented it
constexpr auto begin Const
strengthening. No except no
except could read or true dear
if this zip again strengthened
requires enable costs begin end
because it's the same.
Return iterator true. Do you
have this again perfect.
Uh context. Perado end.
Noexcept, when is and noexcept
false because we're not the
constant one strengthened.
If Constexpr commentary
interview return iterator false
deaf this end. Otherwise return
Sentinel false to depend.
Cam.
And then Cortex Broudo end, we
are const.
No, except when IS and noexcept
true strengthened OK acquires
naval const, begin, end nothing.
If constexpr common range
constant review return iterator
true. Do you have this spend?
Otherwise return Sentinel true
zip end.
Cat.
It's esperado size.
And then strengthen, no, except
if no. Except we can say zip
size.
OK, strengthened require size
range interview returns of size.
Sex burrito size.
We are const.
Noexcept if no except zip size
OK still strengthened. Require
size range of Const interview
returns zip size OK and a class
definition.
Uh deduction guide.
Template on class F which is the
funk.
Class dot ranges is it transform
view from function ranges ref to
do zip transform view of funk
and views. Alt ranges dot OK.
Uh, yeah, that's the
constructor. Yep, we saw that.
Now, is it transform fund? This
is all specified by the
expression of equivalent stuff
in the standard, so that's why
it doesn't appear here.
There's nothing else missing
here. OK, so I think I can
actually minimize this.
The last bit.
Why are we going public again?
Ohh I lost my place. We closed
up transform view deduction
guide. Opening up views now we
have this transform struct so.
Struct under score capital ZIP
transform fund, private stuff,
public stuff. OK, so.
Here we have a static constexpr
bool.
Template on class under score
kept a fun class. dot under
score kept types starter,
classroom bool, under score kept
is invocation noexcept.
Uh, we're Lambda, we're mark.
No, except if constexpr size of
dot our types is zero, we have
nothing.
This says equivalent to.
Using decayed funk is decayed T
funk return.
Wow. What? What? What? Even is
the syntax? My brain is refusing
to parse this.
Return.
OK, there's too many parentheses
here.
One moment.
OK, then I I can't even realize
parenthesis.
OK, so tell this that this is
C++ KMC.
As pass some nice parenthesis
highlighting. OK, so we've got
some why are there? There's a
comma operator in here. OK, this
start to look better. What does
this auto? This is that language
feature that Tyler called out.
That's why my brain can't
process it cuz it's future
technology. My brain is not
upgraded yet.
OK, so returned no except of
this expression.
We have.
A comma operator.
Hence this extra layer of
parentheses.
We are avoiding hijacking by
void casting. Interestingly, the
first one is being void cast
even though conventionally we do
the 2nd. But this is just a
comment so fine.
Why are we checking the decal
VALIS? No, except.
But then why do we?
Yeah, that doesn't make any
sense. We can always do this and
then.
What is the invoke result T?
Decay that type. I don't know
what empty does and then is that
of view. And then can we copy
that? But I don't know what this
is doing. What is the standard
he say?
OK, clearly we're saving the the
hardest question for last here.
Oh, that's up here. OK, I guess
back to split view.
Oregon draft OK?
I've used the transform. That's
this thing.
Oh yeah, OK, so this is what I
was trying to be.
Copied here that the no except
of the whole expression is
expression equivalent to
whatever F was.
But that's kind of weird because
once you give it to zip
transform like it's there like,
who cares whether true or not.
I I guess it I guess expression
expression equivalent has to
Ah there.
handle that.
Expression equivalent means that
if you're evaluate F, it has to
But we don't.
be evaluated in the equivalent
expression.
Since there's no way to avoid
that right for an
implementation, we can't make
that expression disappear in the
library somehow.
Right.
But that said that.
But in the.
Doesn't need to be reflected in
implementation code. That's
And then yeah, in the no except.
super weird.
OK, so this should probably go
away.
And.
Well, we'll see about the actual
code here, but yeah, this is
super weird. Do we even like the
things? Do we even need this
comment? Like, I know Tyler is
trying to explain, and I
appreciate it.
Yeah, I don't like the comment
at all.
That there's a transformation
happening I I think I think
merely citing.
Umm, the standards that it's
implementing would be
sufficient.
Rather than trying to explain
what we're trying to explain,
what it's doing when studying
the standard should be
sufficient.
OK, let's ask for removal of the
comment.
OK, let's see.
Hi.
Thanks for including a yeah, I
don't know. It's not freeze like
that.
I'll I'll blame Casey, Casey and
IUM.
I think that it would be simpler
to.
That's what I'm here for.
You to.
Leave me.
It's all Casey. Well, it's it's
ranges. So ultimately it is all
your fault.
Because you started it or you
were critically involved in the
the standardization of it and
4928 range zip transform view.
Should we just say 2?
Or two one.
If ease is an empty pack.
But by all formed otherwise
this.
I say just maybe 2.
Um.
Because that covers all the
expression equivalent.
Umm.
Maybe. Maybe we should explain.
Whoops, we should explain a
little bit why we're nervous
about this, the.
This thing here.
In the current comment.
Is extremely strange.
Umm.
This is always no except so
there is no reason to mention.
It.
Here.
Came back should mentioned. We
saw that it's trying to match.
Umm.
The void aff here.
Whoops. Whenever I magnify, it's
where, Umm, we saw that.
It was trying to match law and
the standard ease, but simply
citing the relevant paragraph is
easier and less confusing. OK,
how's it sound? Casey and I
think that it would be simpler
to cite N 4928 range ZIP
transform overview two in the
current comment voids to decadal
funk ref is extremely strange.
This is always no except so
there's no reason to mention it
here. We saw that it was trying
to match it void.
F in the standardese, but simply
sign the relevant paragraph is
easier and less confusing.
OK.
Go back to preview and then and
then change the split.
OK, slightly overtime, but I
think we can finish this very
soon.
OK, is invocation, no, except if
there's no types then.
Is it true that it's always
true? UM.
Yeah, we don't have to do
anything.
Yes, it returns an empty view.
As the transformation.
Yeah.
And everything to do with MTV is
no except.
Otherwise return.
OK.
Otherwise, let me split this a
bit more. Otherwise return no.
Except can we make a zip
transform view with parentheses?
Because that's what we do for
views out of stood decal funk.
And that is matching the F and
then stood decl types dot and
that's matching the ease.
OK.
Because.
Otherwise it would attempt to
construct.
The transform view from just the
funk and that would be weird, is
that the theory?
Or try to figure out like why do
we need the special case here at
all?
Because you cannot instantiate
zip transform view with zero
ranges.
It's statically forbidden by the
constraints on the class
Ah.
template so that we don't have
to make it make sense or have a
Ah.
specialization just for 0.
OK, but the the the zip
transform view.
This thing the object, this is
the one that.
Views colon, colon zip transform
will accept 0 ranges, sure, and
Yeah.
Zero and expect something to be
piped to it.
it yeah.
I think right.
No.
No, OK, that's not how.
OK, but OK, it'll accept nothing
then, OK.
Ohh does it take a count? It
probably doesn't.
It's hard to do that piping
thing with things that take
arbitrary numbers of branches,
likes of view and sip transform.
Ah OK Ohh, because it because it
needs to take two things.
So I suspect that they are not
rigid after objects. Yeah, right
Ah OK, got it.
there CPO's, but not range
adaptor objects in the in the
wording, so they don't need to
do the piping.
OK.
OK, I think I've mostly followed
what's happening here. Man, this
stuff is complicated. OK, so now
enable CPO.
Template class under score kept
perfect class dot under score
kept type static. Expert Bowl
enables CPO. Also ugly no except
if constexpr precise dot types
is zero. OK so more special
casing.
I'm guessing that's this using
under score capital. Decayed
funk is deck T funk. That's this
FD.
OK, so this is matching the path
standard ease which Tyler
sighted. If Constexpr move
constructible FD which is
decayed funk and regular
invocable FD ref which is
decayed funk RAF.
OK, this says if it's false.
Or if the Katie blah is not an
object type.
OK, so hold on. If I think we're
organizing this.
If this thing is true and if
blah is an object type.
Are we not checking the object
type bit here?
Why is there?
OK, I'm a little concerned that
we're not checking this bit.
OK, but let's skip that for now.
If law and blah is false, then
itself harmed. So let's test if
constexpr move constructible,
decayed funk and regular
invocable decayed func ref.
One is true. Do cool thing. If
it's false then itself formed.
OK. Ah. OK. So then if it's
true.
Or they're using not void
instead of is object.
Yeah, I think I think that's
what it's being decayed. So it
Is that is that the problem?
might end up being the same.
That's an interesting shortcut,
so let's see if this is correct.
Invoke result TFD ref.
And then.
The Standardese says The thing
is, well, The thing is well
formed when the decay of that is
an object type.
Umm.
Decay transforms well, first the
strips off references and CVS
and it transforms functions to
function pointers and arrays to
object pointers.
So that's like all the stuff
that you could possibly return
from a function. A function
either returns like an object or
reference or void. We've already
decayed away references, so
you're gonna get an object type,
possibly a function pointer or
array element object pointer,
unless it's void. So I think
this is a correct
simplification. What do you
think?
Umm that instead of checking
decay and object type this just
says hey you invoke result. Are
you any kind of void? If you are
then this is bogus.
I think so. I'm agreeing for
now.
OK.
I'm gonna go look at the primary
type categories, but I agree.
Do you think it's worth?
I do you think it's do you think
it's worth comment?
It's an interesting
transformation.
I don't necessarily think it's
worth coming, but are you usual
rules? If you do anything super
clever, then you should come in
it to a record. How clever you
were and B avoid having other
maintainers wonder what you were
doing. I think it deserves
Yes.
comment.
OK, I will complete.
This OK, unless like you look
into it.
I do now completely agree that
it's correct.
OK. Well, yeah, certainly if you
don't think it's possibly
correct, then it definitely
deserves a comment. But if you
can find that it's incorrect
then then we should also fix it.
This appears to be correct.
Casey Carter is going to verify.
No, I did.
Umm.
Ohh you you. Oh, you did. OK, so
you think it is correct but.
I did I I went and looked at all
the primary type type categories
and yes, void is the only thing
that a function can return.
That's not an object type.
CPP Boyd to be precise.
Do you think it merits a
comment?
I don't know we we both were
concerned that it was wrong
initially, but we figured out in
however many minutes that it was
right. Does that close enough?
Yeah, but those minutes were
powered by years and years of
suffering. Through looking at
type traits. So maybe to save
other contributors from
similarly brain exponent. Yeah,
Alright, fair enough.
Fair enough. Let's throw a
comment.
I'm trying to think of. Yeah. Or
in order to save us some time,
5-10 years down the road, once
we've forgotten all of these
things, which is more likely.
OK, I think here we should
probably again just simply cite
range of transform overview, but
here we can cite bullet .211.
UM.
Ah, the KT. So two on one.
Umm.
But.
A, C and I.
Had to think for a moment.
To.
Understand what was happening.
It would be good to comment.
This.
By sighting.
Blah.
Come with this by.
Saying that it implements,
should we say implements more
efficiently?
Or just implements blah.
Maybe more efficiently.
OK, this is a correct
transformation that standardese.
But Casey and I had to think for
a moment to understand what was
happening. It would be good to
comment this by saying that
implements range, zip transform
Overview 211 more efficiently.
Oh, and I forgot the standard.
We should always cite the WP.
When we say paragraph numbers.
OK, great. Did I make that
mistake elsewhere when we cite
paragraphs?
Umm, no, I got it right there.
OK, good.
OK, otherwise return false.
And I was wondering, can we just
simply smash this together with
like and and? But I think the if
constexpr person needed to
needed to delay evaluation of
this invoke result T.
No, we're already incisive dot
types.
It seems like this whole thing
could be simplified to if
constexpr blah and blah and
blah.
Rather than the return false,
what do you think?
Move constructible. Ohh, we
don't know regular invocable
Maybe.
until we get here.
Yeah, I think this is the the
way it has to be phrased,
because if you don't know that
decayed funk ref is regular and
vocable, then you can't say
invoke result T it would scene.
But in this context would be
hard error. So I think this is
necessary unfortunately.
Umm, OK, so what's going on
here?
Wow clang format. What are you
even doing? I was like, I can't
even parse this, but it's like.
Yeah, I'm very disturbed. I
commented about this in chat.
OK, Shi had a comment here that
suppress clang format.
Yes, I think so.
OK.
At the very least, for those
lines in the else clause.
Umm.
Hey.
Yeah, Clang format has really.
Mess this up. We think it
merits.
A suppression here.
OK. Umm, otherwise, uh, I guess
that's this thing. Return
requires given a funk rough ref
under function types ref dot
under args can we make zip
transform view out of stood
forward functions stood four
types args dot OK good.
And the last bit public template
class, under score capital fund,
class dot under score kept types
requires enable CPO funk types.
There should be no discard.
Because why would you invoke the
thing unless you want to use it?
Constexpr auto operator Prinn
Pren take a funk. Refer a
function typestuff.org Const
strengthening no except when is
invocation noexcept. Given funk
and types.
If constexpr size types is 0
then using.
Decayed funk is decayed. T of
the decal type of function.
Wrapped in parens.
Interesting.
Do we need to wrap it in parens?
If we don't, we will get funk
riff Raff, but we're decaying
anyways.
If we do wrap in parens, we
always get an L value.
But then we decayed anyways.
It's not harmful.
It's a little weird.
I'll accept it.
They're trying to reflect
something in the specification
with that and.
Ohh.
They're probably wrong to do so,
so it they're really
questionable.
Why we're doing that?
OK. You think the punch should
be emitted here?
Because we just immediately
decay. Ohh no, here it is. Let
FDB decay T decltype double
parent F.
OK.
It's what the standard says, so
deviating from that is weirder,
so I'm I'm happy with this.
So decltype double printf is
bunk refresh.
Right.
And then we go to K that away.
So probably the standard is
doing something unnecessary.
Decltype printer in function is
funk ref.
So they're using it. They're
using a different type than what
Uncraft. Ohh. Because we have a
name.
the spec says.
Yeah.
But at the end of the day, they
want to.
They should just be using decay
T funk.
Oh, good point. Like? Yeah, why
bother with the ref we already
have? We're already in the type
domain. I'd like that. OK.
Yeah.
It's very confused by using decl
type of this thing that we know
that decl type of because we
just declared it.
And yeah, it would be much
clearer if this was just Ducati
Yeah. OK.
funk done.
So the standard says, UM, law.
Umm, because it's phrased in
terms of on expression.
Let FBA what is sub expression
of a subexpression.
Russian F who's type it doesn't
already know.
Umm here we have.
Like rough rough function, so we
already know the type.
And notably.
Friend function.
Is always on.
L value that that that is a
difference, right? Brent
functions always null value
cause functions got a name,
whereas Brent F could be paren
of some PR value or whatever
expression. So it's not always
an L value. Is that right?
Yeah, give or take.
OK, close enough. Unlike Dev, so
there's all ready a semantic
difference.
Umm. Ultimately we're passing
the result to.
Decay team, so it doesn't really
matter but.
And again, I'll blame you, case,
Carter. And I think it would be
simpler to say decade funk.
And better for throughput.
Yes.
OK, the standards has let FDB,
to KT decltype double printf
because it's phrased in terms of
a sub expression F whose type it
doesn't already know. Here we
have funk ref function, so we
already know the type. Notably
paren function is always null
value, unlike printf, so there's
already a semantic difference.
Ultimately, we're passing the
result OK T so it doesn't really
matter, but Casey and I think
would be simpler to say to KT
funk and better for throughput.
OK, so close.
Uh equivalent, two OK is this
this is the same thing here.
It's more directly matching.
I'm less concerned about this
comma because it doesn't have
that we're decl, Val.
The comments technically wrong,
again because.
Yeah, it's it's wrong again.
And function in effort different
things, right? We we don't know
OK.
Yeah, yeah.
what the type of the argument
expression F is. We can't really
tell we we can tell what it's
decayed type is but we can't
tell if it was a PR value or an
X value by the time it gets here
because we had to bind a
forwarding reference to it.
Right. And that's that's always
an L value. OK, so should we
cite 212 here?
Should we say site two and two
for this one as well because
this is really the problem.
I honestly don't know that I
would say anything for either of
This F.
these.
OK, just drop it. Bridge is
certainly simpler.
Yeah.
I mean, we know we can see where
this is useful though.
OK.
So we know that it's supposed to
be implementing the exceptions
specification.
Or views block and therefore we
never go look at the spec of
Yeah.
views block to figure out why
this succession specification is
And.
so particularly complicated.
Yeah, I agree. Unlike the
transformation here we we know
what to look at so we can see,
oh, this implements that and
it's not super mysterious what's
going on. OK, so let's update
this.
Umm.
Drop this comment entirely.
But.
Readers of this.
Commentation.
Should.
Already know to be looking at
the standard's side by side. OK,
how does this look, Casey? And I
think they would be simply to
drop this common entirely in the
current comment. Void is
extremely strange. As always.
No, except I was trying to match
void and Standardese, but
readers, readers of this
implementation, she already know
to be looking at the standard
subside.
OK, so that applies to the whole
comment and then below I will
also mention that this comment.
Umm.
Similarly.
Or.
Similarly to the comment
somewhat above.
We think that.
This comment.
Should.
I'm simply be dropped.
OK, see notes that.
Umm.
This comment is subtly.
Uh, wrong because void function.
Is not quite the same as.
Void F.
In the standard ease.
Better to avoid the headache and
tart.
OK. Similarly to the comment
somewhere above, we think that
this comment should simply be
dropped to Casey notes that this
comment is subtly wrong because
void function is not quite the
same as void F in the standard
is better to avoid the headache
entirely.
OK.
Otherwise, we're going to return
an empty view of decay T. The
invoke result T of decayed funk
Raff OK, that that's good.
Otherwise return a zip transform
view. Straightforward functions
strip four types, arcs export
stood in line, cuts expert zip
transform fund zip transformer
experience, close namespace
views. And let's make sure that
we're actually in C + 23, which
I think we are because we are.
Going to do ranges as container
let me scroll up before right
after zip. We're good, which I
think we are.
I forgot to check this
originally. Yeah, we just
defined zip zip transform is
right alongside. There's no
jumping out of 23 mode or
anything, so we're still in 23
mode. OK, that is the product
code. Wow, that was very
enlightening.
And it's viewed. I have to come
back and review the test later.
Umm, so I will request some
changes.
Thanks.
This.
Looks great.
We were all this time. I'll
blame myself. I was able to
review all of the product code
during our video code review
this week. I still need to look
at Test CPP.
OK, thanks. This looks great. I
was able to review all the
product code during our video
code review this week. I still
need to look at Test CPP request
changes OK and I do think I
submitted everything and nothing
is pending.
OK, reviewed. Excellent. We did
it and we only ran like 30% over
time.
OK. And I, yeah, I think we we
learned a lot which is always
It wasn't terrible.
good. I don't see any questions
in the comments, only some
Nope.
commentary from Casey.
I I give an explanation of why
Sentinel for incidental 4 don't
have default arguments.
Ah, OK, I guess I can repeat
that here.
It took me a minute to remember
it. It's historical information.
Uh, because it's it's it's a
type constraint because we say
Yeah, we often use it as a type
constraint, yeah.
Sentinel 4I S.
Yeah.
OK, so the default argument
would be too confusing that that
makes sense. Yeah, I remember
seeing that type and strength
thing and get confused about
where the type goes. So adding
more confusion there would be
way too confusing.
Make it even worse. Yeah. LLVM.
You hated it. And.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got rid of that quick.
OK. So thanks for sticking
through this long code review.
Thanks to Tyler Brawl for
submitting this awesome PR and
getting us closer to having a
complete implementation of C is
supposed 23 view zip the paper
we will see you next time.